hello and welcome to swipe coming up
let's get it on
why more tech companies are moving into
music on your bike check out the latest
cycling gadgets to help you hit the road
webby winners New York celebrates some
of the Internet's biggest stars and from
side-scrolling shooters to sci-fi RPGs
we've got the lot on this week's review
online music plays are giving companies
instant access to a community of
passionate users but who's cashing in on
the growing trend and what are the
consequences for the music industry
Sky's Katie Spencer reports if you can't
build a music tech company it seems like
now is the time to buy one it's no
secret the music industry is changing
for the first time since Apple
introduced the iTunes Store ten years
ago digital sales of music are down and
the era of streaming music platforms and
acquiring them is trending sometimes
it's a it's a matter of being at the
right place at the right time and
getting user traction quickly Spotify is
a company that went into an industry
that's very difficult industry to make
money and people discounted them
immediately saying you know it's it's a
hard company you're never gonna make
money
it's a impossible business and they
turned it around when you try
the battle between streaming and
downloads shifted up a gear this week
with the release of Coldplay's new album
not only his ghost stories become the
fastest selling UK album of the year
it's also only out on iTunes so are
these exclusive deals likely to become
more commonplace Rory Gallagher is one
of a number of musicians who fills
royalties from the streaming a leading
artists shortchanged anybody in it it's
mostly cause that the owners of this is
you're just free you page we're seeing a
growing trend in music tech acquisitions
Apple may be paying just under two
billion pounds for music streaming
service and headphone maker Beats
Electronics and Twitter has been
circling internet audio sharing service
SoundCloud
Thun pics is an app that allows you to
post a picture with a 30-second song
clip a social network that claims to be
the first to be built based and funded
in Britain it's not kind of easy it's
gonna be hard but we're doing this
because we love it we're excited about
the opportunity I mean have you ever met
anyone in your life that doesn't love
music you know every person that we show
it's just like it's so excited for tech
startups that hit the right notes the
potential is huge Pandora
by far the biggest streaming music
company but not successful for users
outside of the US Australia and New
Zealand has around 76 million monthly
users and is worth about 3 billion
pounds music streaming service Spotify
is paying global subscribers also agree
to 10 million this week and SoundCloud
boasts a 250 million plus user base and
was most recently self valued at four
hundred and fifteen million pounds I
think it's fair to say that streaming is
probably going to be the way that we
listen to music in the future because
you just get such a vast library of
tracks to listen to at actually a pretty
low cost how we listen is changing and
unless sites like iTunes can find a way
to level the playing field more of us
could be ditching downloads in the years
to come take you Spencer sky news it's
just a tap away
you're watching swype coming up a
celebration of the Internet's finest at
this year's webbie's but first more and
more of us are getting around my bike
these days and when it comes to
high-tech gadgets
cycling is a massive market right now
from helmet cams their health sensors
how do you know what's good and what's
not well we thought we'd send cycling
journalist Simon whiten off to Richmond
Park to test a few out first part we're
looking at today is the Nano folding
bike it's an innovative little folding
bike and I think it's really good
because it's a sort of bike that could
influence them transport policy make
people think about the way they use
bicycles it would easily fit into the
boot of the car
he's very light you can easily move it
on to the train or you know take it into
your office anything I didn't get on
with very well was the gearing I thought
the gearing could have been better it
retails for 600 pounds this one bra was
going to cost you well over a thousand
pounds this is a good value bike once
the nana's great
it's very low-tech there was what
high-tech keep coming into the booming
cycling market and there's one thing
that no wannabe Pro roadies should be
without though and that's a Garmin and
this is the first Garmin computer there
was launched about ten years ago so I
can compute XM GPS it completely
revolutionized the market because up
until then everyone was just training
with heart rate monitors and Garmin have
just launched this one this is the edge
1000 computer not only can you use as a
GPS computer to find out where you're
going we can also record your training
on it with things like cadence speed
power output heart rate and so on and
it's completely feature packed if you're
going off and you're doing these epic
rides whether it be here in Richmond
Park or you going to the Alps or the
Pyrenees then it's all very well
recording your train on it on some like
the Garmin but a great thing to do is
actually record your actual ride on a
helmet camera there's loads of different
helmet cameras available on the market
the GoPro is probably the most famous
and most well-known but that is very
much like a normal sort of camera the
great thing about something like this
which is the drift innovation go s but
it's actually streak lines and it looks
like it should be on a bike so French
you can mount it on your handlebars like
so so a nice aerodynamic shape the lens
part here actually rotates you can mount
in different positions you're going to
put on the side like that it's full 1080
HD and it actually records at 60 frames
per second which is pretty substantial
so the picture quality is very good this
one retails for 320 pounds which is you
know it's a substantial amount to spend
on it on a camera battery life is really
good three and a half hours you can
support a 64 gigabyte SD card in it so
you've got plenty of room to record even
the longest of rise one great new
product is called the ice dot crush
sensor this is basically as it sounds a
crush sensor which you fit on to the
back of your helmet and the sensor part
of it will detect if you're in an
accident and immediately start a
countdown via bluetooth connection to
your mobile phone which will then text
your ice contacts so your in case of
emergency contacts and it will then
notify them that you have likely been
involved in a crash and send
GPS coordinates of where that crash
occurred so this is the C sense
intelligent bike light rays easy to
mount
on your bike very easy to remove the
great thing about this light it's an
intelligent byte light so actually
senses what's going on around a sense of
the light levels it sends it as the
speed of the cyclist it's moving out it
senses whether you're going up a hill or
not and it which it responds and flashes
more vividly depending on what you're
actually doing so if you're coming to a
junction you're slowing down it will
flash more vividly if it suddenly gets
darker it's a cloud cover or it starts
to rain or whatever it'll flash more
vividly I think I can show that quite
easily I just cut my hands over to you
can see how it starts to bright and to
where flush more vividly there yeah the
C sense intelligent byte light retails
for forty five pounds for a single light
or seventy eight pounds for a pack of
two lights you know it's it's a pretty
good investment there's nothing else
like it on the market at the moment and
I think if you're sort of cyclists to is
commuting on a regular basis at night or
maybe early in the mornings or you're
going out and you're training in sort of
you know build conditions this is a
great safety device
you're watching swiped coming up the
mini-drone that doubles as a snack but
first
so actors have the Oscars musicians well
they've got the Grammys but what about
the stars of the Internet
well the webby awards are all about
honoring excellence online the New York
median Patton Oswalt served as the host
of the 18th annual webby awards and
there's one rather important rule for
webby winners where the acceptance
speeches have to be five words or less
now I know a lot of you're like well
that's not a lot of words well you can
get a lot done in five words all right I
think therefore I am
hmm nice this baby is yours
Jack night unfortunately some of the
evenings winners were more successful at
it than others don't make me rip your
throat out
when taylor schilling the star of
netflix prison comedy oranges the new
black went to collect Best Actress it
turned out she wasn't all that good at
multitasking not when it came to
counting and speaking the singers behind
what does the Fox say picked up the
webby for their viral hit
the Norwegian comedy duo went for brutal
honesty with their acceptance speech we
came for free food
Kickstarter picked up a web for the
breakout site of the year and Street
artist Banksy was the Webby Person of
the Year actor George Takei was honored
for a video he made celebrating how
retirees use technology clearly the Star
Trek legend was enjoying getting one up
on a former cast mate
Shatner eat your heart out M&C Saatchi
won for its hashtag virtual pride
campaign to support gay rights in russia
during the winter olympics collecting
the award on behalf of the advertising
agency was a Vladimir Putin impersonator
beautiful who certainly knew how to win
over an audience Nikola Jude Sky News
you're watching swype coming up we've
indie puzzlers and action adventures in
this week's games review but first
here's a roundup of anything you might
have missed over the past few days eBay
has asked it's 233 million users to
change their passwords the company says
a cyberattack compromised its database
which contained encrypted user
information things like names email
addresses phone numbers and dates of
birth were vulnerable but not financial
or confidential information what the ICO
is doing about this is we're actively
looking at the situation with a view to
launching a formal investigation because
this is on the face of it a very serious
breach
google has overtaken rival Apple to top
the list of the world's most valuable
brands according to a new survey the
search giant is worth 94 billion pounds
against Apple's puny 88 billion the FBI
is said to be seriously reconsidering
its no tolerance policy towards
employing people who smoke marijuana The
Wall Street Journal quotes FBI director
James Comey as saying the agency is
grappling with the question of whether
the restrictions prevent the recruitment
of hackers the online storage service
Dropbox
photo op bubbly the mobile app links
photos and audios from one location to
create a photo sphere it's been quite an
expensive few months for Dropbox given
its recent acquisition of photo and
video cloud storage app bloom and
document collaboration service hacked
pad Netflix has announced plans to
expand its presence in Europe by the end
of the year the us-based TV and movie
streaming company wants to launch in
Germany and France among other countries
on the continent Netflix launched in the
UK in 2012 strips face greater
challenges in providing dub content a
new region and finally the world's first
mini drone made from a carrot has taken
to the skies on the recipe well it would
seem you just need to chop one into four
to make the crunchy frame and then
scrape out a few holes for the
electronics not terribly practical but
might be good if you fancy a snap we're
flexing our fingers on this week's
review from side-scrolling shooters to
sci-fi themed RPGs our man in the know
Daniel Krupa has been taking a look
transistor is a very stylish indie game
that's coming to PC and PlayStation 4
it's when people who made Bastion a few
years ago and it's kind of an action RPG
and now it's got a beautiful world
design there it's kind of if Blade
Runner met Tron but also looks kind of
Art Nouveau there's a beautiful original
looking landscape and you players read
who is a lounge singer who's had a voice
stolen by this oppressive regime and you
have a talking sword again kind of very
video game concept but it's a very
interesting narrative in the way that it
makes you work to find out what's
happened so you go through this world
and you start piecing together the
narratives it really makes you work for
it and gameplay wise it's not all that
challenging but it's kind of actually as
in it requires reaction times but
requires thoughtful planning as you'd
expect from a more kind of strategy game
so it's really satisfying blend and it
makes you if you use those kind of games
inmates you try new strategies in a
really interesting way
super time force a you know it's a banca
style and it is a kind of bonkers game
one the main characters is a dinosaur
with a skateboard and it'll be like
crazy video game stuff and it has this
really gorgeous aesthetic retro design
where it's all pixel art so it looks
like a really old game but that kind of
all hides at its core that it's got a
very ingenious gameplay concept now I'll
try and explain this I'll probably name
really badly because it involves time
travel but essentially you start off a
level it's quite a short level and it's
60 seconds you can get to the end of
level you'll probably die what you can
do is you can rewind time select a
different character and then play
alongside your first character again so
effectively you become your own backup
and then you can do this multiple times
at the end of the game
you've got 15 characters on the screen
and each one of them is you you've
controlled them all in previous
playthroughs it's a really original
concept so I think it lets you play with
time in a way that only really video
games can so Thomas was alone is a game
that's been kicking around for a few
years it's been on PC to put on
PlayStation but this week it's coming to
a wider audience like a lot of games are
doing these days
coming to iPad and it's a really simple
minimalist platformer and will you
played not as kind of standard
traditional characters but as abstract
shape so Thomas the problem is Thomas is
a red rectangle and all the platforming
is quite simple you can't get to the end
the level overcome some obstacles but
the thing that really elevates Thomas
was alone is the script it's narrated
throughout by British actor Danny
Wallace and it's really heartfelt it's
really genuine that's really witty and
it does this amazing thing it makes you
imbue these abstract shapes that have
very mundane names like Thomas and John
with really feelings you create
connection with them which is strange
since they are just abstract shapes but
it's a recession game and if you haven't
played it worth checking out on iPad
first thing to say about Kirby triple
deluxe as you should say with all kind
of Kirby games if you want to challenge
or you light your games that demand a
level of skill
Kirby's probably not for you but what
Kirby offers is kind of a really vibrant
fun charming world that's what he's
always been doing really well and this
one's no different it's not a
challenging but it uses the 3d s
wonderfully 3d s as a 3d screen and it
uses all the kind of tricks that you
would expect them to use in that kind of
game playing with perspective and it has
a lot of variety and automates this
kirby is really charming and user
it's kind of a second-tier Nintendo
character he's not Mario but it's still
a really good game and its really good
outing for Kobe thanks Daniel and that's
it for this week remember you can catch
up with the breaking tech stories all
week on Sky News where I found out
smartphone apps and sky news calm see
you next time bye bye